does anybody really think that they've
applied these laws evenly to past
presidents to Hillary Clinton to others
who have had classified information they
are launching incredibly aggressive
vitriolic rhetoric based on zero facts
people are going to get hurt if you're
truly concerned about saving the soul of
America what we cannot have are agencies
that are wheeled against citizens of our
of our country this is a tough time in
our country we have too much distrust
and too many of our institutions
time now for the panel let's bring in
Byron York Chief political correspondent
of the Washington examiner Washington
Post columnist Mark Thiessen and Harold
Ford Jr former Tennessee Congressman
also co-host of the five Byron yesterday
the Attorney General said that he
personally signed off on this search
warrant because he believed that
bringing these documents out of
Mar-A-Lago back into the possession of
the U.S government was a service for the
country sounds like a lot of politicos
on the hill disagree
well look this is serious I mean the
justice department has impaneled a grand
jury it's issued subpoenas and now it's
executed a search warrant and they're
clearly investigating the former
president for alleged crimes of
mishandling
classified information but still the
problem is we don't know what he did uh
the the information along with the
search warrant listed uh alleged
classified documents being picked up by
the FBI but we don't know what it's
about we had one report saying it was
about nuclear weapons we've had other
reports saying it's really really
serious but we don't know really hard to
figure out you know in 2018 Lisa Page
testified
that the FBI had discussed with the
justice department charging Hillary
Clinton under the Espionage Act nothing
came of it the same thing might happen
here
um Mark you used to work with classified
information at the White House as did I
all the time uh some of the there's this
item list take a look I'm going to
summarize this for you guys real quick
but we've got a receipt list of the Seas
materials from aralago so it includes
some things like info on the president
of France a binder of photos a
handwritten note that could really be
anything as Byron points out but then we
also have confirmation that it includes
various secret and top secret documents
does it matter what specific information
is in these documents they belong to the
government of the United States not to
the former president
look mishandling classified information
is a serious issue but here's the thing
the the warrant says that that Trump had
11 sets of classified documents
including four sets of top secret
special Access program documents which
is you and I both know from our time in
government is the highest level of
classification you can have but Jim
Comey told us in that in 2016 that
Hillary Clinton had a hundred and ten
classified emails on her private server
including this is a quote seven email
chains concerning matters that were
classified top secret special access
level programs and on top of that the
justice department investor Inspector
General reported that those those
classified documents were compromised by
Foreign intelligence services that seems
a lot more serious than what's happening
here and the other difference is intent
you know did Donald Trump pack up those
boxes did he unpack those boxes does he
know everything she actually put
classified information into an
classified email that takes physical
effort you have to type it out you can't
just move it cut and paste it from one
to the other so she had intent and they
still didn't rate her house or
prosecutor Harold um the president's
supporters including a whole lot of GOP
members of Congress say today
essentially what took so long if the
justice department suspected or knew
that the former president had these
documents that compromise National
Security in any way why did they wait to
carry out the raid
now so close to the midterms 90 days out
well thanks for having me on and happy
happy weekend and Friday to all you know
Jillian I don't know the answer to that
question but I have to think that uh
they do uh I would Echo what's been said
this is serious no president former
president's been charged or should say
not charged but there's an investigation
underway and we know that Espionage is a
part of the investigation
and that's serious if I were a former
president I hope to be able to say that
one day I would as all of us do I would
I would come on television tonight and
say I have no clue what these people are
talking about they've investigated they
are investigating they've come into my
home I don't know what they could have
found that would make them think that I
should be under investigation for
Espionage now I've heard some people say
that the president there should be a
higher standard for former president
maybe there should but the founders I
don't think believe that the founders
were brilliant they were not perfect but
they believed that presidents and
congressmen and Senators former ones I
happen to be on the lower end of that a
former one we should go back and live in
our communities and be be in the
communities and be behave like we're in
a community yeah and finally I don't I
just don't I don't understand how we we
don't think he should be investigated
like this if it's true I will say this
if there's nothing here everyone has
said that this president has done this
or that should come back on television
and say wow this was wrong and the
justice department was wrong but we'll
we don't know that and we should wait
right lightning fast I want to make sure
we get to winners and losers while I
have you guys here Byron you're up first
winners and losers the Internal Revenue
Service is my winner when the house
votes it's already voted to pass this
are we Hardy voted to pass this they're
rich the loser is the American taxpayer
who's going to face more audits
mark
my winner is Karen tumulty who's of my
Washington Post colleague fellow
All-Star panelist who just came home
after uh after successful bone marrow
transplant looking forward to uh to have
being back on the panel with her one day
very very soon my loser is Eric Adams
the mayor of New York City who has
declared his City a sanctuary City but
is calling uh Governor Abbott
Un-American for sending illegal
immigrants to the sanctuary he set up
well congratulations and best wishes to
Karen I know that sounds like she's
getting married but we really do all the
best to her uh Harold you're up last
winner Bill Russell they retired his
number the NBA the winner the loser
people who choose violence over voting
our system is based on people voting not
being violent towards people you
disagree with
well said gentlemen thanks so much you
really did do that lightning fast for me
I appreciate it hi winner Brian Kilmeade
I want you to do me a favor I want you
to click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now